hey everyone this is kevin from
thechestwebsite.com and today we're
going to be going over the hanging
bishop trap in the french defense french
defense starts out with e4
e6 one of the quickest ways to tilt
someone playing e4 from white is to play
the french defense so e6 and then d4
d5 one of the most common responses for
whites just to play knight c3 and then
the one over variation with bishop
b4 so all pretty common lines here
if white wants to get tricky they can
play the alekhine gambit and that is
knight to e2 it looks like it's blocking
off this light square bishop but white
has other plans with this variation i
think it's pretty good because yes white
does give up the pawn on e4 but they're
able to get this back at a later
variation if you want me to do a
dedicated video just on the outer kind
gamut feel free to let me know in the
comments below
but in this particular version we are
going to be looking at pawn to a3
forcing the bishop to move bishop's
typically going to take on
c3 and then the knight takes back here
you can see this knight already
attacking the pawn on e4 black can
continue by saying yeah if you want to
take that pawn that's fine i'm gonna go
ahead and counter attack get knight to
c6 more pieces developed into the game
plan the queen and the knight are both
attacking the pawn on
d4 so how does white continue well okay
they need to be pretty aggressive
themselves bishop b5 pinning down the
knight to
the king here on e8
knight to e7 similar as we saw before
the night coming to e2 is just saying
hey if you want to take my knight that's
fine i can just replace it with my own
knight and black also doesn't have to
worry about the dark square bishop
getting involved into the game it's not
blocking that off because the bishop
from f8 already came in exchange on the
c3 square
now if white wants to continue to put up
the pressure they can play bishop g5
these are all pretty common moves from
white in the alekhine gambit not going
out of the box just yet and from here
black can play pawn f6
saying yes go ahead and force the bishop
back the bishop's usually gonna come
back to e3 just centralizing a little
bit keeping this pawn on e4 at bait
doesn't want it to push up remember
white eventually wants to get this pawn
back they are down a pawn and material
and so getting that pawn back and they
just don't want to mess up their their
pawn structure themselves because that's
how they're going to gain the advantage
in the end game so bishop to e3 it also
defends this pawn on d4 so both the
bishop and the queen are defending it
then we have f5 from black so it says
hey i want to hold on to this material
on e4 you can see any time black does
this it does weaken the king's side
board just a tad so if they do decide to
castle on the king's side uh just has a
little bit of uh
air in front of it that white can attack
now white can play queen to d2 to set up
to castle on the queen side and this is
one of the concepts you'll usually see
in the on kind gamut is white's looking
to castle on the queen side and then
just throw everything at the king side
of black which usually if you're playing
against the french defense
it's kind of this slow game and you
don't have a lot of your attacking
weapons and so this is one variation
that you'll see it says hey i just want
to throw everything at my opponent
that's why i played e4 in the first
place and so castling on the queen side
is one way to do this so after queen d2
we may see castle on the king side
castle on the queen side from white now
knight d5 and this is where we start to
get into what the trap would look like
and how white can fall into a hanging
bishop trap now from here from white's
perspective they should really just take
this knight on c6 give black double
pawns on the sea fowl it's not terrible
for black they can really control the
center of the board with all of these
pawns they can really just overwhelm
their opponent but i think this is the
better play
for
for white because now they can just
continue with what we talked about h4
and just throw everything at the king
side of the board but they can make a
big mistake and so i think from black
standpoint if you're playing the winner
wear variation in the the black french
defense i think this is something that
you may come across and i want you to be
aware of how you can attack your
opponent that is if they play bishop g5
now this looks pretty strong there's no
pawn that can come and block this off if
they want to move their knight back that
seems a little odd but they definitely
could to defend
this queen here so how do they really
defend the queen they can move the queen
for sure but it looks like everything is
protected but unfortunately it is not
black has the move e3 and this is what
white was trying to stop when they
brought the bishop back to is having
black play the move e3 black is still up
that pawn in materials you have to keep
that in mind and e3
stops the queen from protecting the
bishop on g5
the first thing we have to understand is
what are white's threats and what
happens if they continue with their game
plan they play bishop to g5 attacking
the queen so if they just continue and
take that queen what can black do well
first thing they can just take the queen
on d2 but this is also check and this is
where white's going to lose in this
variation because white has to deal with
that threat they take the pawn on d2
which that pawn remember
was an extra pawn for black so it's
black already recognized that palm is
going to come off the board now it's
just doing additional work and it allows
black now because white had to do with
the check to come back take the bishop
on d8 and so while both sides are equal
in pawn material
black is now up an entire minor piece in
this case a knight so that's not going
to work the bishop just coming down
taking on d8 is not going to work so
what's the other option well if they
take with their pawn on e3
well now the queen no longer defending
that bishop on g5 so the queen could
just come up so you can probably see the
last row option is the bishop takes on
e3
but this loses to the move
pawn to f4
now there's a few variations we're going
to look at on how they can continue the
first one is what happens if the bishop
takes on f4 well this is not going to
work because now the knight can take on
f4
let's say the bishop takes on c6 well
now the pawn can take on uh c6 yes they
can attack our knight if they want to
but then it comes back here and all of a
sudden you can see
black is up still that minor piece
they're up a bishop in this example
which is not going to go well for
them so the bishop taking on f4
is not a viable option but the bishop is
now trapped so maybe they try something
else maybe they go with knight takes on
d5
okay well now black can play queen takes
on d5
and you can see both the bishops are
under attack and we'll get to how they
can both be hanging here in a second but
there's kind of two options we can look
at from here one is what if the bishop
now takes on f4 the knight's not on d5
anymore so it can't take that bishop but
now black can just take the other bishop
on b5 so that's not going to work
because again you can see black is still
up that minor piece
the other option is to go ahead and try
to take this knight on
c6
but now black has two options yes they
could just go ahead if they wanted to
and take the bishop on e3 and this is a
viable threat that white's going to have
a hard time dealing with and it's okay
for black but black actually has an even
better move and that is to play the move
queen to a2 because they are threatening
queen to a1 checkmate okay well white
really has to have some air cover so
that the king can move out of here
but where do they really go okay maybe
queen to e2 that's one option for sure
but you can see both of these bishops
are under attack and black can start
picking them off the pawn takes here on
c6 both of the bishops are hanging
now from white standpoint how do they
hold on to the other bishop
well they don't have a lot of options if
they come back to d2 well that's
checkmate okay queen a1 that's going to
be checkmate so the only other option
for this bishop is to play bishop takes
on f4
and now you can see the rook comes up to
f4 so both the bishops are hanging
there's just no way around it at the end
of the day if we come back
to
the bishop coming to g5 attacking the
queen while it looks all fine because
the queen is protecting it black really
has the dagger of pawn to e3 and at the
end of the day white is gonna end up
losing a minor piece potentially more
depending on how it goes from here so
hopefully you guys enjoyed this trap i
always like to look at different
variations for some of the unique
openings that i like to play and the
winner wear variation in the french
defense is definitely one that i like to
play so uh if you guys enjoyed this
video if you wouldn't mind hitting the
like button and letting me know in the
comments below if there's any other
openings that you say do a lot of traps
on this opening because i play it a lot
let me know that lets me
give me some ideas on where to focus for
future videos but thank you guys and
i'll see you in the next video
you